[Música]
vamos a actualizar las noticias de la
economía con Juan Pablo lucumí Juan
Pablo saludo para usted nuevamente y acá
estamos nuevamente con la apertura hora
de Wall Street y con otras noticias que
no son el mejor panorama empezó otra
gran Ronda de despidos en Facebook esto
es lamentable cuantos recortes habrá y
cómo se dieron cuenta los empleados de
la noticia como casi siempre se dan
cuenta Ángela les llega un correo que
les dice hoy trabajarán desde casa o
algunos simplemente les dicen Pues
presentemos de sus servicios todavía no
se sabe a cuántos afectará pues para
responder a su pregunta este nuevo
recorte pero Se presume que hace parte
de los 10.000 despidos que el director
ejecutivo Mark Zuckerberg habló pues en
marzo el año pasado en noviembre Soccer
dijo que eliminaría aproximadamente al
13% de su fuerza laboral equivalente a
11.000 puestos de trabajo y lo que
supone La Ronda de despidos más grandes
en la historia de la compañía todo esto
bajo la idea de buscar un año de
eficiencia como anunció el dueño de la
empresa Entonces ya habló de 11.000 más
otros 10.000 veremos y otras compañías
también en camino Bueno pues una noticia
muy dolorosa Juan Pablo vamos a pasar
ahora a Europa allá también hay
problemas con el tema laboral hay otra
Ronda de huelgas de trabajadores en el
país y usted nos cuenta específicamente
Ángela en los empleados de los
aeropuertos en düsseldorf Hamburgo y
Colonia bohn se pudo ver este jueves sus
aeropuertos prácticamente vacíos luego
de que el sindicato verde y de Alemania
convocará a una nueva Ronda de huelgas
en busca de aumentos salariales se
espera que la huelga afecte a 50
empresas y más de 100.000 personas luego
de que la asociación aeroportuaria adv
haya confirmado que por lo menos 700
vuelos serán cancelados
bueno el dato de inflación de Alemania
ya salió y puede tener impactos sobre
estas huelgas que se están realizando
Así que le pido que lo revisemos en esta
sección A qué tan altos están los
precios en la mayor economía de Europa
Sí nosotros aquí lo revisamos en su
momento cuando salió el dato pues
bastante fresco pero los trabajadores
dicen que sueldos no alcanzan para sus
necesidades básicas teniendo en cuenta
el aumento de precios la inflación
entonces en la primera economía europea
alcanzó en marzo el
7,4%, un descenso desde el 8,7% de
febrero Pero todavía muy por encima del
objetivo del Banco Central del 2%
escucharemos a continuación a
trabajadores de pues este sector Pero
entonces antes de eso revisemos entonces
que la inflación espera que esté para el
2% pero está todavía en el 7,4 todavía
muy lejos Bueno si le parece como no
tenemos mucho tiempo para escuchar los
testimonios le quiero pedir que pasemos
a Francia porque también está tomando
medidas importantes para estimular la
economía la segunda del continente Así
que cuéntenos el gobierno les dijo este
jueves que planea recortar el gasto
público Y esperan un crecimiento
económico mayor una reducción de su
déficit presupuestario anual y el de su
deuda Pública que es una de las más
altas de la zona Euro el déficit
presupuestario de Francia alcanzó el
4,7% del pib en 2022 y se pronostica que
será más alto este año con un 4,9% del
pib mientras los planes del ministro de
economía francés rondan el 2,7 todavía
está muy lejos escuchemos lo que dijo el
jefe de la cartera económica
el primer Pilar es el crecimiento no
hace falta decir que la mejor forma de
reducir la relación deuda pib es primero
aumentar el pib y Por ende aumentar la
riqueza nacional nunca hay que perder de
vista que este objetivo de aumentar la
prosperidad de la riqueza nacional es el
objetivo principal queremos aumentar la
riqueza nacional mediante la inversión
Juan Pablo de la Unión Europea habló de
regulación de criptomonedas y este es el
primer conjunto de reglas que el bloque
de los 27 países hace con respecto a los
mercados de los criptoactivos el
parlamento votó por 517 a favor y 38 en
contra respecto a este paquete de normas
que se espera se ha implementado a
partir de mediados de 2024 y en el que
además pedirá a las empresas que ofrecen
servicios de criptoactivos en el bloque
que obtengan una licencia de los
reguladores de la Unión Europea ya
veremos Cuáles serán estas reglas
momento de los indicadores y los indios
bursátiles de Estados Unidos abrieron a
la baja el jueves debido a que los
decepcionantes resultados de tesla at&t
y algunos bancos regionales afectaron
los sentimientos de los inversores
recordemos que cualquier rumor en este
escenario básicamente daña las
decisiones de ellos las bolsas en Asia
cerraron con ganancias luego de que el
Banco Popular de China dijera que con
sus decisiones buscarán que las tasas de
interés sean apropiadas y que el crédito
se mantenga estable y motivadas por el
crecimiento de China que se aceleró al
4,5% en el primer trimestre las bolsas
europeas siguen operando en terreno
negativo con Los indicadores de Alemania
Francia y Reino Unido con pérdidas
menores al 1% y cerremos con la cifra
del día son los 110 mil dólares que vale
Este robot de forma de perro llamado
spot la máquina fue comprada por la
administración Autónoma de transporte de
París en Francia y tiene como objetivo
ayudar a los inspectores del metro de
París a preparar la red ferroviaria
regional centenaria y es que el perro
robot cuenta con una cámara de 360
grados con sensor infrarrojo que le
permite capturar datos térmicos y
visuales precisos seguramente mejor que
los humanos Mire yo no sé esto es un
comentario completamente al margen Juan
Pablo Pero estos robots me recuerdan a
un capítulo de una serie que se llama
Black mirror son igualitos y es
apocalíptica turista completamente
completamente pero en el caso de la
serie en un mal sentido aquí pues
esperemos que preste todo el servicio
que se necesita y que ayuda a la
comunidad Así es Juan Pablo gracias Nos
vemos mañana con mucho más claro que sí